bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi à sète à
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
on commence tout de suite avec le
sommaire l'ancien président et candidat
à la primaire de la droite et du centre
étaient hier dans les yvelines
son premier déplacement en ile de france
depuis l'officialisation de sa
candidature nous y étions et le conseil
départemental a fait sa rentrée le point
sur sa politique concernant les collèges
à suivre dans cette édition
et enfin polémique à voisins le
bretonneux un foyer de placement de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse va
réouvrir nouvelle controversé les
explications et de la politique pour
ouvrir ce journal nicolas sarkozy était
hier dans les yvelines afin d'évoquer
son programme pour l'éducation
c'était son premier déplacement en ile
de france depuis l'officialisation de sa
candidature à la primaire de la droite
et du centre
entre dédicaces et tables rondes
l'ancien président n'a jamais évoqué
ouvertement ces sociétés 10 hier regardé
comme si de rien n'était il serre des
mains fédé selphy signe des autographes
de nicolas sarkozy était dans les
yvelines pour parler éducation après une
table ronde à orgeval avec des
professeurs d'école il s'est rendu à
poissy pour dédicacer son livre tout
pour la france l'occasion pour l'ancien
président de la république de mesurer le
soutien indéfectible de ses partisans
aucun doute aucun doute je toujours
confiance en lui je le soutiendrai
jusqu'en 2017
je veux l'aider enfin on peut tous les
désirs et si on rassemble les français
ou rim
on peut les nier je vois pas qui d'autre
peut nous sortir de ce guêpier dans
lequel on est aujourd'hui entre les
attentes des attentes à calais le social
qui nous prend un argent monstrueux
aujourd'hui les subventions des communes
qui disparaissent comme
neige qui fond au soleil voilà donc je
pense qu'il ya que monsieur sarkozy oui
aujourd'hui franchement qui peut faire
quelque chose pour la france soutient
également du côté des élus locaux alors
que nicolas sarkozy a vu son agenda
judiciaire se remplir en début de
semaine avec l'annoncé de son éventuel
renvoi devant le tribunal dans l'
affaire des comptes de campagne
vous avez les les comptes de monsieur jo
ce père n'était pas exacte on le sait
maintenant monsieur dumas raconter ça et
le conseil constitutionnel a préféré
regarder ailleurs ça a été la même chose
pour les comptes de monsieur balladur
ment cette histoire de comptes de
campagne ça me paraît être un péché
véniel
les gens font la part des choses voilà
faut arrêter de penser que les gens ne
sont pas capables de voir ne sont pas
capables de voir les énormes officiel
les câbles que tendent
la majorité actuelle pour entraver la
route d'un homme vers la présidence
calme serein devant une salle acquise à
sa cause le président des républicains a
tenu à rassurer s'il en était encore
besoin ses partisans rien ne l'empêchera
d'être candidat aucune polémique aucune
manoeuvre
aucune manipulation haution 2 soit elle
ne me détournera d'un centimètre de ma
volonté absolue de construire avec vous
une alternance forte une alternance
franche une alternance perceptible par
tous les français
avant la présidence nicolas sarkozy
devra passer par la case primaire les
candidats officiels seront connus le 9
septembre pour une élection les 20 et 27
novembre prochains et autres
déplacements dans le département
récemment celui du ministre de la
défense jean yves le drian et les têtes
à saint germain en laye en fin de
semaine dernière pour inaugurer le siège
de xv ou une entreprise de haute
technologie spécialisée dans les
domaines de la navigation
l'imagerie et l'océanographie ses
clients sont aussi bien militaires que
civiles et côté les grands enjeux
commerciaux les grands enjeux
technologiques
les grands enjeux militaires du 21e
siècle ce seront les enjeux maritimes et
la france est le deuxième pays du monde
pour sa superficie maritime
on ne le sait pas assez est donc complet
si l'on à des entreprises capables
d'explorer d'innover dans ce domaine
elles peuvent être en tête dans la
compétition mondiale
c'est le cas dans certains domaines et
c'est le cas en particulier la sur les
centrales inertielles dont on a parlé
mais aussi sur l'acoustique sous marines
dont c'était x blue a une spécialité
jean yves le drian micro à dire une
première autre visite c'est celle de
martine pinville secrétaire d'état
chargé du commerce de l'artisanat de la
consommation et de l'économie sociale et
solidaire elle se rendra demain jeudi
lui septembre à fontenay le fleury pour
visiter l'atelier de réparation à
d'appareils électroménagers odom
ce déplacement sera bien sûr l'occasion
pour la secrétaire d'état de rappeler
l'action gouvernementale en matière de
protection des consommateurs et le
conseil départemental adhésives in a
fait sa rentrée cette semaine pierre
bédier le président du conseil
départemental s'est rendu au collège
rené descartes de fontenay le fleury
c'était ce lundi 5 septembre
l'occasion de mettre en avant la
politique pour cette rentrée en faveur
des établissements yvelinois un
reportage signé nicolas kirilow 8,72
millions d'euros d'investissements cette
année à 430 jusqu'en 2020 le département
des yvelines maintient ses ambitions en
faveur des 138 collèges privés et
publics du département pour cette
rentrée à cinq établissements sont
encore en travaux
c'est le cas notamment du collège rené
descartes à fontenay le fleury fin du
chantier prévue pour l'an prochain
nous considérons que l'investissement
dans le secteur des collèges est
absolument stratégique à la fois pour
les familles pour les enfants mais aussi
pour l'attractivité du territoire
et puis à côté de ces dépenses très
lourdes il ya bien entendu un effort
fait sur le numérique des tablettes
numériques 15 % des collégiens illinois
ont une tablette à titre expérimental et
puis leur sécurité ou en partenariat
avec l'état et là
et les maires nous allons chercher des
solutions sécurité numérique
restauration scolaire les priorités sont
nombreux cette année un volet insertion
est également mise en place avec le
recrutement de 228 bénéficiaire du rsa
la 1100 agents dans nos collèges à y ait
une grande partie d'une grande partie
mais on se calme du personnel qui fait
des tâches un petit peu difficile ils
sont arrêtés de temps en temps pour des
problèmes de dos ou autre et on doit
pallier à leur remplacement donc on a eu
l'idée donc de pouvoir mettre en place
directement dans nos établissements des
personnes qui sont bénéficiaires du rsa
donc et de les mettre en situation
d'emploi donc ils sont là en plus pour
pallier éventuellement l'absence de
personnel de l'agent d'entretien agent
de restauration agents d'accueil la
construction d'un collage innovant a
également été évoquée celui ci verra le
jour en 2010 9 dans le quartier du
val-fourré à mantes-la-jolie et
permettra le développement d'une
nouvelle méthode pédagogique axé
notamment sur le travail en groupe les
ajustements de la carte scolaire se sont
poursuivis durant cette première semaine
de rentrée dans les écoles yvelinoise
afin d'apporter une réponse aux
dernières situation restait en suspens
quelques nouvelles mesures d'ouverture
de classe ont donc été prises ces
derniers jours notamment une septième
classe de maternelle à l'école
moreau de magny les hameaux et nous
prenons à présent à la direction de
voisins-le-bretonneux avec cette
polémique après plusieurs années de
fermeture le centre de placement de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse va
réouvrir la décision du ministère de la
justice
soulève de nombreux mécontentements et
incompréhension du côté de la mairie de
l'opposition mais aussi être des
riverains les explications sont signées
nicolas landry à voisins le bretonneux
le centre de placement de la protection
judiciaire va réouvrir après une
fermeture en 2012 il devrait accueillir
six jeunes entre 16 et 18 ans ayant
commis des délits
objectif permettre leur réinsertion une
décision reçue avec une certaine réserve
par les riverains de ce côté là on est
est très inquiet sur le devenir de la
tranquillité du quartier
je ne suis ni pour ni contre je suis
plutôt inquiète
opposé à cette réouverture le conseiller
municipal olivier alfonso dénonce le
manque de transparence du maire je ne
connais pas la condamnation de ces
jeunes qui vont intégrer la maison qui
est derrière moi donc s'il ya là les
informations je les invite à les rendre
publiques lors du conseil municipal ou
informé les élus que nous sommes
habitant le quartier olivier tyrol a
rédigé une pétition contre cette
décision
53 personnes ont déjà signé le document
pourquoi on n'y a pas contacté les gens
disent on attendait on va se réunir on
va vous expliquer les choses qui est ce
qui se passe non là c'est on nous met
devant le fait accompli et vous n'avez
qu'un droit c'est de vous taire le maire
alexandra rosetti affirme avoir
communiqué dès qu'elle a eu connaissance
du projet elle a organisé une réunion
publique avec les principaux riverains
et elle se veut rassurante en prenant le
dossier en main avec la création d'un
comité de suivi spécifiques
j'ai eu le sentiment quand même que les
directeurs que nous avions en face de
nous était vraiment décidé à tout faire
pour que les choses se passent bien que
ce soit très cadré voilà les jeunes ne
sont pas sûrs voisins en journée ils
vont dans d'autres centres ils sont
occupés ils réapprennent l'autonomie on
aura des réunions régulières pour voir
comment les choses se déroulent les
travaux sont en train d'être finalisé la
résidence devrait ouvrir à partir du 1er
octobre
et revenons un sujet plus léger avec la
rentrée scolaire on reprend bien sûr les
activités samedi dernier à elancourt ses
tenues
l'annuelle forum à des associations au
complexe sportif de l'europe
plus d'une centaine à sociale plus d'une
centaine d'associations pardon était
présente
zoom sur les nouveautés de la rentrée
avec camille lambert et corinne fallon
donner la liberté à chacun d'accéder à
la culture et de la partager
offrir plusieurs vies aux ouvrages tel
est l'objectif du projet boîte à livres
inauguré par le lion's-club d'elancourt
aqua li na au forum des associations
organisé le week-end dernier à elancourt
l'objectif c'est de permettre la lecture
papier à des gens qui en sont de plus en
plus privée alors privé par les
mauvaises habitudes pas parce qu'on veut
pas qu'ils fassent les livres viendront
désormais à la rencontre des passants
avec deux boîtes installées à la clé de
saint pierre et au village autre
nouveauté de la rentrée l'association
family singh 78 créer un peu plus d'un
an par christelle 6 l'air et son époux
présente pour la première fois au forum
des associations
c'est une association qui permet de
réunir des familles entendant sourds et
malentendants pour faire des ateliers
enrichir son vocabulaire en langue des
signes
ces ateliers créatifs échanges parents
enfants sont organisés un samedi par
mois
au total plus d'une centaine
d'associations culturelles sportives et
sociales étaient présentes
on parle à présent de la fête de l'aïd
el kébir les ventes de moutons pour
cette fête ont commencé mercredi 7
septembre à trappes réservé aux
habitants de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui ont reçu des
invitations elles seront ouvertes au
public jeudi 8 septembre
jonathan est du plessis est éleveur de
moutons ils participent à ce dispositif
pour la quatrième fois et chaque année
ils vont plus de 1400 annuler
l'opération est pour lui un succès je
vous propose de l'écouter cette année
l'appareil a été modernisée on a
installé un appareil différent qui
permet justement privilégié bien-être
animal et d'assurer une meilleure
qualité du sacrifice l'objectif c'est
vraiment deux concilier une pratique
cultuelle un sacrifice et en même temps
des conditions d'hygiène irréprochables
les moutons 90 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires est réalisé sur lie sans
l'aïd
aujourd'hui les plantations ne
tournerait pas je vous le rappelle les
sacrifices auront lieu le mardi
le lundi 12 pardon et le mardi 13
septembre
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
jour merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
retrouve demain pour une nouvelle
édition du jt et vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée